in a previous episode we went over how
logs are aggregated across
all of gcp and how to navigate them
in this episode we'll talk about error
reporting a google cloud tool available
to help you better capture errors
categorize them and manage their life
cycle
[Music]
application level errors happen
sometimes even in production
and the last thing you want is scrolling
through your logs to find the relevant
information
instead cloud logs reporting
aggregates and displays errors produced
in your running cloud services
it automatically groups together error
and critical
level errors from your application into
groups
and can notify you if a new error group
appears
this works across many languages and is
supported out of the box by cloud
functions
app engine cloud run compute engine
and gke any of your application errors
can be surfaced using error reporting
provided that they use basic formatting
or that they simply call the error
reporting api
errors are grouped and deduplicated by
analyzing their stack traces
so you only see one entry per error type
each error entry provides a summary that
helps you determine
when the application started to produce
the error how often it
occurred and how recently it occurred
one thing i really like is the ability
to set a resolution status for each
error
it defaults to open and can be set to
acknowledged
resolved or simply muted
errors can also be linked to an issue in
a bug tracking system
this is really powerful and thankfully
you do not need to stare at the console
in search of potential errors
instead you can be notified in real time
via email or my favorite via the google
cloud mobile app
but maybe the most important thing about
cloud era reporting is that it requires
zero setup for
all of google cloud's serverless
products and it's really just a few
simple steps
for other products if you are a
developer
and if restarting or redeploying your
application just to incorporate
some new logging statements sounds
painful
then be sure to keep your eyes open for
an upcoming episode
for a truly unique solution to this
problem using
debug log points in a future episode
we'll also talk about tools available to
help you better understand the problem
that led to any of those errors and most
importantly
how to fix them if you like this video
please like subscribe comment share
and look forward to more google cloud
essentials videos
[Music]